now there's no reference Liam to the
investigation into the autopilot crashes
somebody has died driving on auto auto
auto pilot in a Tesla he does say that
at some point autopilot Tesla autopilot
will be 10 times safer than the average
of us cars but how big a problem is this
issue with autopilot well I think it
could be a big problem and I think
actually the the fact that he talked
about it a lot kind of obliquely in the
plan speaks to that and I think also the
fact upfront he was talking very much
about justifying the the integration of
the solar panels business with the car
business that was also also featured
very heavily I mean in some ways I think
the release of this plan now is meant to
head off
quite a bit of the criticism that's
that's been laid out on the company over
the past month or so shares dropped and
I wonder James do you think investors
are tired I really don't I think you
know number one from the autopilot
perspective there's still some question
of an investigation as to whether or not
the technology was misused I think
number two you know we've had the you
know privilege of riding along another
competitor autopilot or sort of
similarly powered vehicles I think the
technology is very much here to stay and
if you look at the way the stocks
reacted to that news it's quite minimal
I think the bigger reaction in the last
month or so has been the Solar City
announcement and that's really where I
do think investors are looking for a
little bit more hand-holding trying to
understand how you know truly understand
the synergies here and most importantly
you know we're talking about an auto
business that needs quite a bit of cash
already with significant hurdles as I
alluded to earlier looming you know how
much cash are they going to devote now
to the Solar City sort of franchise
within the Tesla ecosystem you know I
think those are the bigger questions
that still have been left unanswered the
business issues aside Liam you do have a
consumer base here that loves their
Tesla's like customers are obsessed with
with their cars yeah um still I wonder
what Tesla be better off
a private company as a private company I
think like uber yeah I think looking
back maybe they wish they could do that
because certainly you can raise a lot of
money outside of the public eye now but
I would point out that the stock price
is still higher than it was before they
announced the SolarCity deal which is
kind of telling apart from the consumer
base there's clearly a very very strong
fan base among investors and I think you
would need to see something go really
wrong with one of the products for that
to for that to come into question James
would you agree fans and faith and in
Elon Musk even despite that what some
people think is a some Sun it was a
ridiculous to even propose that Tesla
merge with Solar City no I look I I
totally agree with the fact that the
stock has recovered since its initial
reaction to the Solar City transaction I
don't necessarily think that that means
that people have an investor's have
given Elon sort of a pass or a blanket
pass I think we're in the midst of a
sort of a very bifurcated sort of binary
outcome situation they're either going
to hit a very I think aggressive and
albeit very impressive if they get their
target for the model three or they're
going to fall short that I think is
where you have to be focused right now
the rest of this I mean if they hit
their targets on the model three the
Solar City transaction is irrelevant so
I think there's quite a bit more baked
into the auto side of the business in
terms of expectations and maybe that's I
think one of the key reasons why the
stock has held up irrespective of some
of these sort of near-term issues